okay yeah
the view just went there Megan McCain
calling joy behar the b-word on live TV
after a heated discussion about what
else Donald Trump and the 20/20 election
a friendly argument is a great thing on
the show but it turns out it wasn't that
big of a deal after a commercial break
the ladies offer this explanation I love
the word [ __ ]
Joey and I call each other a [ __ ] all
the time and text each other [ __ ] I
know you're comfortable with it she
knows I'm comfortable with it I also
enjoy fighting with you and I don't care
if you're calling me a [ __ ] I don't
care
Whoopi Goldberg explained that they
hadn't used the word on-air for a while
because some former co-host who weren't
named used to get offended by it I mean
we're very passionate women and I think
these are really passionate times and
sunny Hostin said she only called Megan
out on using the word because she was
worried what the audience might think a
lot of times some of the viewers get
offended so well well this probably
isn't the show for you if you're
offended easily and both Megan and joy
have been clear about their relationship
away from the table they're good it's
like a older sister I never had but I'm
telling you I've never had more fun
fighting with anyone on TV can I do it
joy babe that's it so we always make up
okay
[Music]